[Music]
we're matching we both got pains how you
look so cool squad goals couple goals
old cousin we're going to scare Peter
pine how much are you gonna bet that
they're gonna make a big deal out of me
having this on I swear to god they're
all going to point it out everyone has
been freaking out all morning because it
was a 10:00 a.m. instead of 1:00 p.m. so
we have to hurry the [ __ ] up
this vlog is probably not going to be
your typical vlog well well well look
who it is
what are you doing you guys look good
we should stay there I'm going in the
car now bye
hey guys I got a surprise for you yeah
thanks for giving me the ammo bag hey
doing their brand
I've got a wife a kid I got kids man
give me your money
thanks buddy
get up don't you see you be double cross
you would never Cosmo Michael you ready
you've been double-crossed you job cry I
got more ammo boy ah ah you shot me in
the [ __ ] head has another one what
the hell is wrong with you you shot me
in the chin you played no Gaston it also
you're the one the boss keeps talking
about
Wow oh I know that seem so you're the
one the Bosch keep talking about oh sure
how much on the driver I'm sorry I'm
[Music]
sorry you guys doing blacking out the
windows why do you look so suspicious
Michael what's gonna happen what's gonna
happen when I can tell you well then
don't
so it's your first day on scare
PewDiePie how do you feel excited yeah
this is all you dreamt about everything
yeah I mean it's beautiful colors
I the [ __ ] are you doing yeah it's hard
stop all right you're not gonna bet a
gal I played the live estranged
yesterday and I was thinking how can she
get oh whoa
life is strange taught Michael how to be
so hard to be strong
[Music]
hello coming up what is this yeah
don't you want Maya to topple coma
welcome to cooking will be dica today we
are going to make cheeses banana uclan
one cheese's I mean one banana you take
cheese's you stick it in Z banana
it gives that consciousness very good
taste like cheese
who doesn't like cheese and banana and
also if you feel really crazy you can
get eyes my accent is already gone oh
look at that banana nut very beautiful
looks just like piles penis this is the
finest plate from the pigs butthole you
stick it in you stick it in like that
just just stick it just stick it in like
oh oh oh that's good
[Music]
and there you have a Felix tonight it's
a good happy night this is what we did
in Sweden when we were born in high
school how you do it like this and then
you have to keep it on so you have to do
that to keep it going
Wow so you lose what's it to me you have
to put your knuckle down and I get to
shoot it
the father can't kill me why you see in
the grace for this yeah Oh am i doing it
bread you going down bu she's gonna
flick it in my eyes watch Oh finished
our game oh oh come on that's a good get
him get him
put it down properly these guys got it
oh no no no tell me that but it doesn't
look like it wait doesn't like show up
anywhere near as badly hurt really hurt
yeah do it
no don't cheat I'm not seeing a problem
you find a vein you can no way I'm not
sure take a pic awesome why is this
ah the Weston nut
Wow look at that you love Norway
disgusting how dare you I didn't do it
who did it well you do this my own
girlfriend
oh hey car sparkles is here hey I'm
looking fabulous I hope I get new socks
good choice no just water we fly out
just before Thanksgiving so we're gonna
celebrate Thanksgiving today how does he
like hey don't look sad looks looks like
no look kind of like like that no look
just normal no no how do you pull off
that kind of [ __ ] thumb that way
it's gonna be like this gonna be like
puppy eyes I got something to tell you
gasps oh my coat is so ugly I can't deal
with it
thank you fun friend I think
oh I think this is pretty wet bread what
do you think
thanks bread that's a strong I want this
right leave me alone it okay now look
good in this massage man should I keep
this look leave it like if you agree no
no tripping no not my goodness here's my
word oh sure I feel like this mustache
needs like a name like Pedro Pi or laugh
all our churches me llamo is Pedro pi
[Music]
oh my god who did that this is just here
who put that there
oh my god is so cute that's so creepy
we've been away all day we have the
doors locked the door was locked
who did this is it uh Lara it's a trump
in yatta isn't it it's a trump pinata
it's a put petrol pipe Arianna hmm
tomorrow on the election day like
tomorrow's election day
we're gonna have some fun with I guess
you can sleep with Petra for now I mean
oh that fits but oh well yeah oh whoa
Trump Trump be Trump hold it man that
was such a fun day these shoots for
scare PewDiePie are amazing compared to
first season it's so much better it's
like 10 times better I really I'm really
excited for you guys to see it I'm
having a lot of fun shooting them at
least they're very long days but and to
do the blogs at the same time like
everyone is working really hard to get
these out every single day so I hope you
really enjoy them
you better is what I'm trying to say you
better [ __ ] and enjoy them you hear
my voice I mean yelling all day
good fun the paddle pie I forgot I had
this [ __ ] Mustang baby looks awesome
hey I'm working it I'm working it you
love it what the hell is all this
feel this is definitely from a fan great
thank you
that's just creepy do you see what it
says
think about vlogging and realize how
easy people are gonna find our address I
don't like that I don't think that's
funny I know they're trying to be funny
but it's not funny I think people think
it's like trollee or like they have some
sort of power over you like I see people
post the address and they're like who
Lucas on the Reuters guys like okay
you're [ __ ] creepy and weird like
I don't know this in that fridge this is
what you get when you have an Italian
girlfriend well I guess that's not mine
Thank You mighty for cooking I know you
are tired I get I get to the past I with
the Italian Agra friar I have a to mix
that otherwise she's not eating yeah all
right that's the end of another burnable
tomorrow is election day
I'm just here dropping up footage to
Brad in case it hasn't clicked already
Brad Michael Oher helping me at it while
I'm here I really owe them a huge thanks
for all the stuff they do I just do the
final cut pretty much I was really
freaking out before I came here and I
really appreciate that they come over
cuz I don't know what to do with the
vlogs but I am just so happy that you
guys are enjoying them so much I really
appreciate all the nice comments and all
the feedback it's really exciting for me
too to be making something that so many
people really appreciate rather than my
standard kind of stuff so I couldn't be
happier about it so thank you guys so
much thanks for leaving a like keeps
showing your support and I'll see you
brush tomorrow with another part of all
we got some exciting stuff coming up
then stay awesome rush
[Music]